ليس مجرد واحدا من ابرز قاده المستوطنين
الذين كانوا يدنسون المسجد الاقصى بل
اقتحم اتامار بن جبير الحرم القدسيه
الشريف كوازيرا للامن القومي الاسرائيلي
اقتحام ضلل به الكثيرين حتى داخل اسرائيل
بعد اتفاقه مع نتنياهو وقاده الاجهزه
الامنيه على تنفيذه في الصباح الباكر ودون
طقوس دينيه
اقتحام استمر 13 دقيقه ولكن هذه الدقائق
حملت تبعات كبيره
لشعب اسرائيل ومفتوح للجميع ياتي الى هنا
المسلمون والمسيحيون واليهود في حكومه انا
عضو فيها لن يكون هناك تمييز عنصري اليهود
سيدخلون الى جبل الهيكل ونوضح لحماس اننا
لا نستسلم ولا نتراجع
عن الاقتحام الذي سبق جلسه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الاولى بثلاث ساعات وراء
اساسه ومحللون اسرائيل في ذلك محاوله
للاعب على كافه الاوطار قاده المعارضه
الاسرائيليه نبهوا الى التداعيات الامنيه
كما رفضت السفاره الامريكيه تغيير الواقع
في القدس في ما وصف الدول العربيه
واسلاميه الخطوه بالاستفزازيه
القياده والفصائل الفلسطينيه حملت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كافه التداعيات ودعت
الفلسطينيين الى التصدي لمحاولات جعل
المسجد الاقصى معبد يهوديه
لمثل هذه الاقتحامات التي تستهدف جعل
المسجد الاقصى معبد يهوديه وهذا انتهاك
لكل الاعراف والقيم والاتفاقيات والقوانين
الدوليه وتعهدات اسرائيل للرئيس الامريكي
ندعو والمقاومه في الضفه المحتله الى
تصعيد الاشتباك والمواجهه مع الاحتلال
الصهيوني في كافه ساحات الاشتباك دفاعا عن
المسجد الاقصى المبارك
دائره الانتهاكات توسعت والتي كان اخرها
قتل الطفل ادم عياد في مخيم الدهيشه في
بيت لحم واقتحام مدينه جنين واخذ مقاسات
منازل شهداء واسرى لهدمها
حضر محللون من انها قد تجعل هذا العام
اكثر دمويه من سابقه
الاسرائيلي سيكون عام قاسي جدا في فلسطين
التاريخيه كلها يعني حتى بالداخل من تلك
السياسه من سياسه بني كبير وسياسه فتنه
اياها المتطرفه
اقتحام الوزير المتطرف في تمار بني كفير
للمسجد الاقصى وقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين ونصف
منازل واعتقال العشرات واقتحام مناطق عده
في الضفه الغربيه في الايام الثلاثه
الاولى من بدايه العامه جعلت الفلسطينيين
كافه اضافه الى دول عربيه وغربيه تحمل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامله المسؤوليه عن
تبيعات الاحداث واعتبارها المسؤوله عن
تفجر الوضع الميداني
الجزيره القدس المحتله